Prof: Well,
now today is obviously a kind
of watershed or transition in
our syllabus.
You remember we began with an
emphasis on language.
We then promised to move to an
emphasis on psychological
matters, and finally social and
cultural determinants of
literature.
So far we have immersed
ourselves in notions to the
effect that thought and speech
are constituted by language or,
to put it another way,
brought into being by language
and that thought and speech have
to be understood as inseparable
from their linguistic milieu--
language here being understood
sometimes broadly as a structure
or a semiotic system.
Now obviously our transition
from language-determined ideas
about speech,
discourse, and literature to
psychologically determined ways
of thinking about discourse and
literature has a rather smooth
road to follow because the first
two authors who borrow from
Freud and understand their
project to a degree in
psychoanalytic terms are
nevertheless using what is now
for us an extremely familiar
vocabulary.
That is to say,
they really do suppose that the
medium of consciousness to which
we now turn--
the psyche, the relationship
between consciousness and the
unconscious--
they really do suppose that
this entity,
whatever it may be,
can be understood in terms that
we take usefully from verbal
thought and from linguistics.
Lacan famously said,
as you'll find next week,
"The unconscious is
structured like a
language,"
and Brooks plainly does agree.
You open Brooks and you find
yourself really apart perhaps--I
don't know how well all of you
are acquainted with the texts of
Freud.
We'll say a little bit about
Beyond the Pleasure
Principle, which is the
crucial text for our purposes;
but plainly apart from the
influence of and the ideas
borrowed from Freud,
you'll find Brooks writing on
what for you is pretty familiar
turf.
For example,
he begins by borrowing the
Russian formalist distinction in
trying to explain what fiction
is between plot and story.
I feel that I do ultimately
have to cave in and admit to you
that the Russian words for these
concepts,
plot and story,
are syuzhet and
fabula respectively,
because Brooks keeps using
these terms again and again.
I've explained my embarrassment
about using terms that I really
have no absolutely no idea
>
of the meaning of except that
I'm told what the meaning of
them is in the books that I am
reading, which are the same
books that you're reading.
In >
any case, since Brooks does
constantly use these terms,
I have to overcome
embarrassment and at least at
times use them myself.
They're a little
counterintuitive,
by the way, if you try to find
cognates for them in English
because you'd think that
syuzhet would be
"subject matter,"
in other words something much
closer to what the formalists
mean in English by
"story."
On the other hand,
you'd think that fabula
might well be something like
"plot"
or "fiction,"
but it is not.
It's just the opposite.
Syuzhet is the plot,
the way in which a story is
constructed,
and the fabula is the
subject matter or material out
of which the syuzhet is
made.
All right.
In addition to the use of the
relationship between plot and
story,
we also find Brooks using terms
that are now,
having read Jakobson and de
Man, very familiar to us:
the terms "metaphor"
and "metonymy."
There's plainly a tendency in
modern literary theory to reduce
all the tropes of rhetoric to
just these two terms.
When needed,
they back up a little bit and
invoke other terms,
but the basic distinction in
rhetoric,
as literary theory tends to
understand it,
is the distinction between
metaphor--
which unifies,
synthesizes,
and brings together--
and metonymy,
which puts one thing next to
another by a recognizable
gesture toward contiguity but
which nevertheless does not make
any claim or pretension to unify
or establish identity--
to insist, in short,
that A is B.
These two terms,
as I say, are understood
reductively but usefully to be
the essential topics of rhetoric
and appropriated by modern
theory in that way.
Now Brooks then uses these
terms in ways that should be
familiar to us,
as I say.
We have now been amply exposed
to them in reading Jakobson and
de Man.
So there is a language of
language in Brooks' essay,
"Freud's Masterplot,"
despite the fact that the
framework for his argument is
psychoanalytic and that he is
drawing primarily on the text of
Freud's Beyond the Pleasure
Principle.
So what does he take from Freud?
What interests Brooks about
Freud?
He is, by the way,
a distinguished Freudian
scholar who knows everything
about Freud and is interested,
in fact, by every aspect of
Freud, but for the purpose of
constructing the argument here
and in the book to which this
essay belongs,
the book called Reading for
the Plot--
for the purposes of
constructing that argument,
what he takes in particular
from Freud is the idea of
structure: the idea that,
insofar as we can imagine Freud
anticipating Lacan--
Lacan himself certainly
believed that Freud anticipated
him--
the idea that the unconscious
is structured like a language.
In terms of creating fictional
plots, in terms of the nature of
fiction, which is what interests
Brooks--well,
what does this mean?
Aristotle tells us that a plot
has a beginning,
a middle and an end.
"Duh!"
of course, is our response,
and yet at the same time we
can't understand a degree of
mystery in even so seemingly
simple a pronouncement.
A beginning,
of course--well,
it has to have a beginning.
We assume that unless we're
dealing with Scheherazade,
it has to have an end,
but at the same time we might
well ask ourselves,
why does it have a middle?
What is the function of the
middle with respect to a
beginning and an end?
Why does Aristotle say,
as Brooks quotes him,
that a plot should have a
certain magnitude?
Why shouldn't it be shorter?
Why shouldn't it be longer?
In other words,
what is the relation of these
parts,
and what in particular does the
middle have to do with revealing
to us the necessary
connectedness of the beginning
and the end: not just any
beginning or any end but a
beginning which precipitates a
kind of logic,
and an end which in some way,
whether tragically or
comically,
satisfactorily resolves that
logic?
How does all this work?
Brooks believes that he can
understand it,
as we'll try to explain,
in psychoanalytic terms.
So this he gets from Freud,
and he also gets,
as I've already suggested,
the methodological idea that
one can think of the
machinations of a text in terms
of the distinction that Freud
makes--
not in Beyond the Pleasure
Principle, but in
The Interpretation of
Dreams in the passages that
you read for today's assignment
taken from that book,
The Interpretation of
Dreams, about the dream
work.
It's there that Freud argues
that really the central two
mechanisms of the dream work are
condensation and displacement.
Condensation takes the
essential symbols of the dream
and distills them into a kind of
over-determined unity so that if
one studies the dream work one
can see the underlying wish or
desire expressed in the dream
manifest in a particular
symbolic unity.
That's the way in which the
dream condenses,
but at the same time the dream
is doing something very,
very different,
and it's called displacement.
There the essential symbols of
the dream--
that is to say,
the way in which the dream is
attempting to manifest that
which it desires,
are not expressed in
themselves, but are rather
displaced on to sometimes
obscurely related ideas or
symbols,
images, or activities that the
interpreter,
that the person trying to
decode the dream,
needs to arrive at and to
understand.
So displacement is a kind of
delay or detour of
understanding,
and condensation,
on the other hand,
is a kind of distillation of
understanding.
The extraordinary thing that
Freud remarks on as he studies
dreams in this book--
published in 1905,
by the way--the extraordinary
thing about the way in which
dreams work is that there seems
to be a kind of coexistence or
simultaneity of these effects.
The dream work simultaneously
condenses and displaces that
which it is somehow or another
struggling to make manifest as
its object of desire.
Now the first person to notice
that there might be--
there are a variety of people
who noticed that there might be
a connection between
condensation and displacement
and metaphor and metonymy,
most notably Jacques Lacan whom
Brooks quotes to this effect:
that the work in everyday
discourse,
in what we say but also in our
dreams and in what we tell our
analyst,
can be understood as operating
through the medium of these two
tropes.
Condensation,
in other words,
is metaphorical in its nature,
and displacement is metonymic
in its nature.
Metonymy is the delay or
perpetual, as we gathered also
from Derrida,
différance of
signification.
Metaphor is the bringing
together in a statement of
identity of the discourse that's
attempting to articulate itself.
Again we see in fiction,
as Brooks argues in his essay,
that these two rhetorical
tendencies,
the metaphorical and metonymic,
coexist--
and of course you can hear the
implicit critique of de Man in
the background--
and may or may not work in
harmony,
may or may not conduce to an
ultimate unity,
but nevertheless do coexist in
such a way that we can
understand the unraveling of a
fictional narrative as being
like the processes we see at
work in the unraveling of
dreams.
So it's these two elements that
Brooks is interested in in Freud
and that he primarily does take
from Freud.
Now this means,
among other things,
that Brooks is not anything
like what we may spontaneously
caricature perhaps as a
traditional psychoanalytic
critic.
Brooks is not going around
looking for Oedipus complexes
and phallic symbols.
Brooks is, as I hope you can
see, interested in very
different aspects of the
Freudian text,
and he says as much at the end
of essay on page 1171 in the
right-hand column where he says:
… [T]here can be
psychoanalytic criticism of the
text itself that does not become
["This is what I'm
doing," he says]--
as has usually been the case--a
study of the psychogenesis of
the text (the author's
unconscious),
the dynamics of literary
response (the reader's
unconscious),
or the occult motivations of
the characters (postulating an
"unconscious"
for them).
In other words,
Brooks is not interested in
developing a theory of the
author or a theory of character.
Now I don't think he really
means to be dismissive of
Freudian criticism.
I think he's really just
telling us that he's doing
something different from that.
I would remind you in passing
that although we don't pause
over traditional Freudian
criticism in this course,
it can indeed be extremely
interesting: just for example,
Freud's disciple,
Ernest Jones,
wrote an influential study of
Shakespeare's Hamlet in
which he showed famously that
Hamlet has an Oedipus complex.
Think about the play.
You'll see that there's a good
deal in what Jones is saying;
and in fact,
famously in the history of the
staging and filming of
Shakespeare--
as you probably know,
Sir Laurence Olivier took the
role of Hamlet under the
influence of Ernest Jones.
In the Olivier production of
Hamlet,
let's just say made it
painfully clear in his relations
with Gertrude that he had an
Oedipus complex.
Again, there were actual sort
of literary texts written
directly under the influence of
Freud.
One thinks of D.H. Lawrence's
Sons and Lovers,
for example,
in which the central character,
Paul Morel,
is crippled by an Oedipus
complex that he can't master and
the difficulties and
complications of the plot are of
this kind.
Moving closer to the present,
an important figure in literary
theory whom we'll be studying in
this course,
Harold Bloom,
can be understood to be
developing in his theories of
theoretical text,
beginning with The Anxiety
of Influence, a
theory of the author--
that is to say,
a theory that is based on the
relationship between belated
poets and their precursors,
which is to say a relationship
between sons and fathers.
So there is a certain pattern
in--and of course,
I invoke this pattern in
arguing that Levi-Strauss'
version of the Oedipus myth
betrays his Oedipus complex in
relation to Freud.
Plainly, Freudian criticism
with these sorts of
preoccupations is widespread,
continues sometimes to appear,
and cannot simply be discounted
or ignored as an influence in
the development of thinking
about literature or of the
possibilities of thinking about
literature.
But the odd thing,
or maybe not so odd--
the interesting thing,
that is, in Brooks' work is
that although the text is not
there to tell us something about
its author or to tell us
something about its characters,
even though character is
important in fiction and that's
what Brooks is primarily talking
about--
although it's not there to do
those things it is nevertheless,
like an author or a character,
in many ways alive.
That is to say,
the text is there to express
desire, to put in motion,
and to make manifest desire or
a desire.
That is a rather odd thing to
think about, especially when
Brooks goes so far as to say
that he has a particular desire
in mind.
The text, in other words,
the structure of the text,
or the way in which the text
functions is to fulfill in some
way or another a desire for
reduced excitation:
that is to say,
the desire which can be
associated with the pleasure
principle in sexual terms and
can be associated with the idea
of the death wish that Freud
develops in Beyond the
Pleasure Principle that I'll
be coming back to as the
reduction of excitation that
would consist in being dead.
In these ways--and it remains
to see whether,
or to what extent,
these ways are cooperative--
Brooks understands the
structure, the delay,
the arabesque,
or postponement of the end one
finds in the text to involve a
kind of coexistence of the sort
that I have been talking about
between relations to the
possibility through desire of
reducing excitation,
being excited,
and reducing excitation.
Now obviously both dreams and
stories don't just express this
desire;
they also delay it.
I'm sure we have all had the
experience of waking up--it's an
experience, by the way,
which is an illusion;
it hasn't really been the
case--and thinking that we have
been dreaming the same damn
thing all night long:
in other words,
that we have just been
interminably stuck in a dream
predicament which repeats itself
again and again and again to the
point of absolute total tedium.
Many of the dreams we have are
neither exciting nor the reverse
but simply tedious.
Whatever excitement they may
have entailed in the long run,
we feel as we wake up that they
go on too long.
Perhaps fiction does have this
superiority over the dream work:
that its art,
that its structure,
is precisely the protraction of
delay to a desired degree but
not unduly beyond that degree.
But it's not just that the
middles of fiction involve these
processes of delay.
It's that they seem also--and
this is one of the reasons
Brooks does have recourse to
this particular text of Freud--
they also have the curious
tendency to revisit
unpleasurable things.
That is to say,
it's not that--the middles of
fiction are exciting.
We love to read and everything
we read is a page turner,
all to the good;
but the fact is our fascination
with reading isn't simply a
fascination that takes the form
of having fun.
In fact, so much of what we
read in fiction is distinctly
unpleasurable.
We wince away from it even as
we turn the page.
One way to put it,
especially in
nineteenth-century realism which
particularly interests Brooks,
is all these characters are
just madly making bad object
choices.
They're falling in love with
the wrong person.
They're getting stuck in sticky
situations that they can't
extract themselves from because
they're not mature enough,
because they haven't thought
things through,
and because fate looms over the
possibility of making a better
choice--
however the case may be,
the experiences that constitute
the middles even of the greatest
and the most exciting fiction do
have a tendency,
if one thinks about them from a
certain remove,
to be unpleasurable.
Why, in other words,
return to what isn't fun,
to where it isn't pleasure,
and what can this possibly have
to do with the pleasure
principle?
Now that's precisely the
question that Freud asked
himself in Beyond the
Pleasure Principle,
a text which begins with a
consideration of trauma victims.
It's written at the end of the
First World War,
and you should understand this
text as not isolated in the
preoccupation of writers in
Europe.
Almost contemporary with
Beyond the Pleasure Principle
are novels written in
England partly as a result of
the making public of findings of
psychologists about traumatic
war victims as the war came to
its conclusion.
Most of you have read
Virginia's Woolf's Mrs.
Dalloway, and you
should recognize that her
treatment of Septimus Smith in
Mrs. Dalloway is a
treatment of a traumatized war
victim.
Rebecca West,
a contemporary and an
acquaintance of hers who wrote a
good many novels,
wrote one in particular called
The Return of the Soldier,
the protagonist of which is
also a traumatized war victim.
So it was a theme of the period
and Freud's Beyond the
Pleasure Principle
contributes to this theme.
Brooks himself likes to refer
to the text of Beyond the
Pleasure Principle as itself
a master plot--
in other words as having a
certain fictive character.
It would be,
I think, extremely instructive
to read it alongside The
Return of the Soldier or
Mrs.
Dalloway for the reasons
I've mentioned.
Okay.
So anyway, Freud begins by
saying, "The weird thing
about these trauma victims whom
I have had in my office is that
in describing their dreams and
even in their various forms of
neurotic repetitive behavior,
they seem compulsively to
repeat the traumatic experience
that has put them in the very
predicament that brought them to
me.
In other words,
they don't shy away from it.
They don't in any strict sense
repress it.
They keep compulsively going
back to it.
Why is that?
How can that possibly be a
manifestation of the only kind
of drives I had ever thought
existed up until the year 1919,
namely drives that we can
associate in one way or another
with pleasure--
with the pleasure principle,
obviously;
with a sort of implicit
sociobiological understanding
that the protraction of life is
all about sexual reproduction
and that the displacement or
inhibition of the direct drives
associated with that take the
form of the desire to succeed,
the desire to improve oneself,
and the desire to become more
complex emotionally and all the
rest of it?
All of this we can associate
with the pleasure principle.
How does this compulsion to
return to the traumatic event in
any way correspond to or submit
itself to explanation in terms
of the pleasure principle?"
So then he turns to an example
in his own home life,
his little grandson,
little Hans,
standing in his crib throwing a
spool tied to a string out of
the crib saying,
"Fort!"
meaning "away,
not there,"
and then reeling it back in and
saying,
"Da!"
meaning "there it is
again": "Fort!
Da!"
Why on earth is little Hans
doing this?
Well, Freud pretty quickly
figures out that what little
Hans is doing is finding a way
of expressing his frustration
about the way in which his
mother leaves the room;
in other words,
his mother is not always there
for him.
So what is this play
accomplishing?
He's got her on a string, right?
Sure, she goes away--we have to
understand this:
we know our mother goes away,
but guess what?
I can haul her back in,
and there she is again.
This is the achievement of
mastery, as Freud puts it and as
Brooks follows him,
that we can acquire through the
repetition of a traumatic event.
So maybe that's the way to
think about it,
but it can't just be the
achievement of mastery alone,
because nothing can do away
with or undermine the fact that
part of the drive involved seems
to be to return to the trauma--
that is to say,
to keep putting before us the
unhappy and traumatic nature of
what's involved.
So the compulsion to repeat,
which of course manifests
itself in adults in various
forms of neurotic behavior--
by the way, we're all neurotic
and all of us have our little
compulsions,
but it can get serious in some
cases--
the compulsion to repeat takes
the form,
Freud argues,
especially if we think of it in
terms of an effort at mastery,
of mastering in advance through
rehearsal,
as it were, the inevitability
of death,
the trauma of death which
awaits and which has been
heralded by traumatic events in
one's life,
a near escape:
for example,
in a train accident or whatever
the case may be.
So Freud in developing his
argument eventually comes to
think that the compulsion to
repeat has something to do with
a kind of repeating forward of
an event which is in itself
unnarratable:
the event of death,
which is of course that which
ultimately looms.
Now it's in this context that
Freud begins to think about how
it could be that the organism
engages itself with thoughts of
this kind.
What is this almost eager
anticipation of death?
He notices that in certain
biological organisms,
it can be observed--this by the
way has been wildly disputed by
people actually engaged in
biology,
but it was a useful metaphor
for the development of Freud's
argument: he noticed that there
is in certain organisms a wish
to return to a simpler and
earlier state of organic
existence,
which is to say to return to
that which isn't just what we
all look forward to but was,
after all, that which existed
prior to our emergence into
life.
The relationship between the
beginning and the end that I
have been intimating,
in other words,
is a relation of death.
I begin inanimate and I end
inanimate,
and Freud's argument is that
there is somehow in us a
compulsion or a desire,
a drive, to return--like going
home again or going back to the
womb to return to that inanimate
state.
"The aim of all
life," he then says,
"is death."
Well, now maybe the important
thing is to allow Brooks to
comment on that so that you can
see how he makes use of Freud's
idea and move us a little bit
closer to the application of
these ideas to the structure of
a literary plot or of a
fictional plot.
So on page 1166 in the
right-hand margin,
the beginning of the second
paragraph, Brooks says:
We need at present to follow
Freud into his closer inquiry
concerning the relation between
the compulsion to repeat and the
instinctual.
The answer lies in "a
universal attribute of instinct
and perhaps of organic life in
general,"
that "an instinct is an
urge inherent in organic life to
restore an earlier state of
things."
Building on this idea,
page 1169, the left-hand
column, about halfway down:
This function [of the drives]
is concerned "with the
most universal endeavor of all
living substance--
namely to return to the
quiescence of the inorganic
world."
Kind of pleasant,
I guess, right?
"The desire to return to
the quiescence of the organic
world."
The aim in this context,
in this sense--the aim of all
life is death.
But there's more,
and this is why novels are
long: not too long,
not too short,
but of a certain length--
of a certain magnitude,
as Aristotle puts it.
There is more because the
organism doesn't just want to
die.
The organism is not suicidal.
That's a crucial mistake that
we make when we first try to
come to terms with what Freud
means by "the death
wish."
The organism wants to die on
its own terms,
which is why it has an
elaborate mechanism of
defenses--
"the outer cortex,"
as Freud is always calling it--
attempting to withstand,
to process,
and to keep at arm's length the
possibility of trauma.
You blame yourself as a victim
of trauma for not having the
sufficient vigilance in your
outer cortex to ward it off.
Part of the compulsion to
repeat is,
in a certain sense--part of the
hope of mastery in the
compulsion to repeat is to keep
up the kind of vigilance which
you failed to have in the past
and therefore fail to ward it
off.
So the organism only wishes to
die on its own terms.
If you are reminded here by the
passage of Tynjanov that I gave
you where he makes the
distinction between literary
history as evolving and literary
history as modified by outside
circumstances,
I think it would be a
legitimate parallel.
What the organism,
according to Freud,
wants to do is evolve toward
its dissolution,
not to be modified--not,
in other words,
to be interfered with by
everything from external trauma
to internal disease.
It doesn't want that.
It wants to live a rich and
full life.
It wants to live a life of a
certain magnitude,
but with a view to achieving
the ultimate desired end,
which is to return to an
inorganic state on its own
terms.
So there is this tension in the
organism between evolving to its
end and being modified
prematurely toward an end,
a modification which in terms
of fiction would mean you
wouldn't have a plot,
right?
You might have a beginning,
but you would have a sudden
cutting off that prevented the
arabesque of the plot from
developing and arising.
Now what Brooks argues
following Freud is that to this
end,
the creating of an atmosphere
in which with dignity and
integrity,
as it were,
>
the organism can progress
toward its own end without
interference,
as it were--what Brooks
following Freud argues is that
in this process,
the pleasure principle and the
death wish cooperate.
This is on page 1166,
bottom of the right-hand
column, and then over to 1167,
a relatively long passage:
Hence Freud is able to proffer,
with a certain bravado,
the formulation:
"the aim of all life is
death."
We are given an evolutionary
image of the organism in which
the tension created by external
influences has forced living
substance to "diverge ever
more widely from its original
course of life and to make ever
more complicated
détours before
reaching its aim of death."
In this view,
the self-preservative instincts
function to assure that the
organism shall follow its own
path to death,
to ward off any ways of
returning to the inorganic which
are not imminent to the organism
itself.
In other words,
"the organism wishes to
die only in its own
fashion."
It must struggle against events
(dangers) which would help to
achieve its goal too rapidly--by
a kind of short-circuit.
Again on page 1169,
left-hand column,
a little bit farther down from
the passage we quoted before,
Brooks says:
… [W]e could say that
the repetition compulsion and
the death instinct serve the
pleasure principle;
in a larger sense [though],
the pleasure principle,
keeping watch on the invasion
of stimuli from without and
especially from within,
seeking their discharge,
serves the death instinct,
making sure that the organism
is permitted to return to
quiescence.
It's in this way that these two
differing drives coexist and in
some measure cooperate in the
developing and enriching of the
good life,
and in the developing and
enriching of the good plot.
An obvious problem with this
theory,
and Freud acknowledges this
problem in Beyond the
Pleasure Principle,
is that it's awfully hard
to keep death and sex separate.
In other words,
the reduction of excitation is
obviously something that the
pleasure principle is all about.
The purpose of sex is to reduce
excitation, to annul desire.
The purpose of death,
Freud argues,
is to do the same thing.
Well, how can you tell the one
from the other?
There's a rich vein of literary
history which insists on their
interchangeability.
We all know what "to
die" means in early modern
poems.
We all know about
"Liebestod"
in "Tristan and
Isolde,"
the moments of death in
literature which obviously are
sexually charged.
There is a kind of manifest and
knowing confusion of the two in
literature--
and Freud always says that the
poets preceded him in everything
that he thought--
which suggests that it is
rather hard to keep these things
separate.
For example,
by the way, the compulsion to
repeat nasty episodes,
to revisit trauma,
and to repeat the
unpleasurable--
well, that could just be called
masochism, couldn't it?
It could be called something
which is a kind of pleasure and
which therefore could be
subsumed under the pleasure
principle and would obviate the
need for a theory of the death
drive as Freud develops it in
Beyond the Pleasure
Principle. Now Freud
acknowledges this.
He says that it is difficult to
make the distinction.
He feels that a variety of
sorts of clinical evidence at
his disposal warrant the
distinction, but it is not an
easy one.
It's one that I suppose we
could continue to entertain as a
kind of skepticism about this
way of understanding the
compulsion to repeat as somehow
necessarily entailing a theory
of the death wish.
All right.
Now quickly,
as to the plot:
desire emerges or begins as the
narratable.
What is the unnarratable?
The unnarratable is that
immersion in our lives such that
there is no sense of form or
order or structure.
Anything is unnarratable if we
don't have a sense of a
beginning, a middle,
and an end to bring to bear on
it.
The narratable,
in other words,
must enter into a structure.
So the beginning,
which is meditated on by
Sartre's Roquentin in La
Nausee and quoted to that
effect by Brooks on the
left-hand column of page 1163--
the narratable begins in this
moment of entry into that
pattern of desire that launches
a fiction.
We have speculated on what that
desire consists in,
and so the narratable becomes a
plot and the plot operates
through metaphor,
which unifies the plot,
which shows the remarkable
coherence of all of its parts.
A narrative theory is always
talking with some satisfaction
about how there's no such thing
in fiction as irrelevant detail.
In other words,
nothing is there by accident.
That is the metaphoric pressure
brought to bear on plotting,
sort of, in the course of
composition.
Everything is there for a
reason, and the reason is
arguably the nature of the
underlying desire that's driving
the plot forward;
but on the other hand,
metonymy functions as the
principle of delay,
the detour, the arabesque,
the refusal of closure;
the settling upon bad object
choice and other unfortunate
outcomes,
the return of the
unpleasurable--all the things
that happen in the structure of
"middles"
in literary plots.
The plot finally binds material
together, and both metaphor and
metonymy are arguably forms of
binding.
Look at page 1166,
the right-hand column,
bottom of the first paragraph.
Brooks says:
To speak of "binding"
in a literary text is thus to
speak of any of the
formalizations (which,
like binding,
may be painful,
retarding) that force us to
recognize sameness within
difference,
or the very emergence of a
sjužet from the material
of fabula.
Okay.
Now I want to turn to Tony
as an instance of the way in
which reading for the plot can
take place.
I also want to mention that the
choice of these materials for
today's assignment is not just a
way into questions of
psychoanalysis as they bear on
literature and literary theory,
but also a gesture toward
something that those of you
whose favorite form of reading
is novels may wish we had a
little more of in a course of
this kind--
namely narrative theory:
narratology.
I commend to you the opening
pages of Brooks' essay where he
passes in review some of the
most important work in narrative
theory,
work that I mentioned in
passing when I talked about
structuralism a couple of weeks
back and work which,
for those of you who are
interested in narrative and
narrative theory,
you may well wish to revisit.
Roland Barthes,
Tzvetan Todorov,
and Gerard Genette are the
figures to whom Brooks is
primarily expressing
indebtedness within that
tradition.
Anyway: Tony the Tow Truck.
I would suggest that in the
context of Beyond the
Pleasure Principle we could
re-title Tony the Tow Truck
as The Bumpy Road to
Maturity.
It certainly has the
qualities of a picaresque
fiction.
It's on the road,
as it were, and the linearity
of its plot--
the way in which the plot is
like beads on a string,
which tends to be the case with
picaresque fiction,
and which by the way is also a
metonymic aspect of the
fiction--
lends the feeling of
picturesque to the narrative.
Quickly to reread it--I know
that you all have it glued to
your wrists, but in case you
don't, I'll reread it:
I am Tony the Tow Truck.
I live in a little yellow
garage.
I help cars that are stuck.
I tow them to my garage.
I like my job.
One day I am stuck.
Who will help Tony the Tow
Truck?
"I cannot help you,"
says Neato the Car.
"I don't want to get
dirty."
"I cannot help you [see,
these are bad object choices,
right?],"
says Speedy the Car.
"I am too busy."
I am very sad.
Then a little car pulls up.
It is my friend, Bumpy.
Bumpy gives me a push.
He pushes and pushes [by the
way, this text,
I think, is very close to its
surface a kind of anal-phase
parable.
In that parable,
the hero is not Tony in fact
but a character with whom you
are familiar if you're familiar
with South Park,
and that character is of course
the one who says,
"He pushes and
pushes…"]
and I am on my way."
[In any case that is part of
the narrative,
and then:]
"Thank you,
Bumpy,"
I call back.
"You're welcome,"
says Bumpy.
Now that's what I call a friend.
So that's the text of Tony
the Tow Truck.
Now we've said that it's
picaresque.
We can think in terms of
repetition, obviously,
as the delay that sets in
between an origin and an end.
We've spoken of this in this
case as--well,
it's the triadic form of the
folk tale that Brooks actually
mentions in his essay;
but it is, in its dilation of
the relationship of beginning
and end, a way of reminding us
precisely of that relation.
He comes from a little yellow
garage.
The question is,
and a question which is perhaps
part of the unnarratable,
is he going back there?
We know he's on his way,
but we don't know,
if we read it in terms of
Beyond the Pleasure
Principle,
whether he's on his way back to
the little yellow garage or
whether--
and there's a premonition of
this in being stuck,
in other words in having broken
down--
whether he's on his way to the
junkyard.
In either case,
the only point is that he will
go to either place because the
little yellow garage is that
from which he came;
in either case--little yellow
garage or junkyard--
he's going to get there on his
own terms,
but not as a narcissist and not
as the person who begins every
sentence in the first part of
the story with the word
"I,"
because you can't just be an
autonomous hero.
On your journey,
and this is also true of the
study of folklore,
you need a helper.
That's part of fiction.
You need another hero.
You need a hero to help you,
and having that hero,
encountering the other mind as
helper,
is what obviates the tendency,
even in a nice guy like Tony,
toward narcissism which is
manifest in the "I,"
"I,"
"I"
at the beginning of the story.
Notice that then the
"I"
disappears, not completely but
wherever it reappears it's
embedded rather than initial.
It is no longer,
in other words,
that which drives the line in
the story.
So the arabesque of the plot,
as I say,
is a matter of encountering bad
object choices and overcoming
them: neatness,
busyness--choices which,
by the way,
are on the surface temptations.
We all want to be neat and
busy, don't we?
But somehow or another it's not
enough because the otherness,
the mutuality of regard that
this story wants to enforce as
life--
as life properly lived--is not
entailed in and of itself in
neatness and busyness.
Resolution and closure,
then, is mature object choice
and in a certain sense there,
too, it's a push forward,
but we don't quite know toward
what.
We have to assume,
though, in the context of a
reading of this kind that it's a
push toward a state in which the
little yellow garage and the
unnarratable junkyard are
manifest as one and the same
thing.
Now as metonymy,
the delays we have been talking
about,
the paratactic structure of the
way in which the story is told--
all of those,
and the elements of repetition,
are forms that we recognize as
metonymic,
but there's something beyond
that at the level of theme.
This is a story about cars.
This is a story about
mechanical objects,
some of which move--remember
those smiling houses in the
background--
and some of which are
stationary, but they're all
mechanical objects.
They're all structures.
In other words,
they're not organic.
This is a world understood from
a metonymic point of view as
that which lacks organicity,
and yet at the same time the
whole point of the story is
thematically metaphoric.
It is to assert the common
humanity of us all:
"That's what I call a
friend."
The whole point of so many
children's stories,
animal stories,
other stories like this,
The Little Engine that
Could,
and so on is to
humanize the world:
to render friendly and warm and
inviting to the child the entire
world,
so that Tony is not a tow
truck--Tony's a human being,
and he realizes humanity in
recognizing the existence of a
friend.
The unity of the story,
in other words,
as opposed to its metonymic
displacements through the
mechanistic,
is the triumphant humanization
of the mechanistic and the fact
that as we read the story,
we feel that we are,
after all, not in mechanical
company but in human company.
That's the effect of the story
and the way it works.
In terms of the pleasure
principle then,
life is best in a human
universe and in terms of--
well, in terms of Beyond the
Pleasure Principle,
the whole point of returning
to an earlier state,
the little yellow garage or
junkyard,
is to avert the threat that one
being stuck will return to that
junkyard prematurely or along
the wrong path.
Okay.
So next time we will turn to
the somewhat formidable task of
understanding Lacan.